evidence of scientific progress that's
how the mexican president described at
russian vaccine sputnik v
adding the country hopes to get millions
of doses of it by march
we spoke with the president of the
russian federation vladimir putin
and he was genuinely affectionate i
invited him to visit
mexico and thanked him for the decision
to send us 24 million doses of the
sputnik v
vaccine over the next two months
meantime in india the final stage of
sputnik v's clinical trials are well
underway and the country's ambassador to
moscow's already had the shot
i took it last week the first dose of
sputnik vaccine
i feel perfectly well many of my
colleagues in the embassy have done so
as well
and i am absolutely certain
that this is part of the normal
precautions that we take during the
pandemic situation
just as we wear a mask we have social
distance
it is also good to take scientifically
proven
vaccines and of course the sputnik
vaccine is one such vaccine
well approval of sputnik v in india
could come within weeks once it
completes trials india is also mulling
making the jab on its territory for both
domestic and global demand
the country's envoy to russia again
tells us why new delhi got involved
it doesn't come as a surprise that we
have such a long tradition
of cooperation between india and russia
that cooperation continued
during the covet pandemic so when
the rdif chief mr kiril dimitrijev
approached
the indian authorities for the testing
of the sputnik
vaccine this was welcomed in india
these phase 2 trials of sputnik vaccine
have been
completed phase three trials were
commenced and we are sure that as soon
as the regulatory approvals
are given in india it will be available
for use in india
our aim is to finally cover the
vaccination of 300 million
indians so it is one of the largest
vaccination programs in the world
but at the same time we wish to reach
out
to our dear friends and neighbors and we
have done so
we have given vaccination
doses supplies have been sent by
air to nepal bhutan bangladesh sri lanka
myanmar
small deeps and this is just the
beginning we do not believe in vaccine
competition
we do not believe in vaccine nationalism
we believe in vaccine cooperation and
friendship
and we intend to extend our hand of
through support for the vaccination
programs of a number of countries
who are in need of this and we will work
through
the un the who as we move forward and
i'm sure
in the weeks ahead there will be
cooperation between india and russia
on the global vaccination programs and
there will be
great potential for cooperation because
the number of the vaccines that are
produced in india will also be used
abroad
and that will include the russian
sputnik
vaccine that will be produced in india
rdif
has been in touch with a number of very
good indian companies
to take this forward and we expect in
the next couple of weeks
a sputnik vaccine after its regulatory
approval
will be available for use in india
and also for export to russia and
and other countries